number one accountability this is gonna
set you free whether it's true or not in
every situation if you always know that
it's always your fault it sounds crazy
but that will keep you crazy happy do
not blame anybody but yourself it will
make you happy it's a huge mindset
number two eliminating entitlement i am
blown away by people's entitlement just
because your mom and dad had sex at the
right exact second doesn't mean nobody
owes you [ __ ] nothing is owed to any of
y'all it is what it is it's like sports
it's a game just because somebody gave
you a scholarship or gave you an at-bat
it's you you're not owed anything the
third one is simple which is be nice if
you realized how life actually plays out
and you will one day when you're 60 70
80 the number one hack the smartest move
be kind be nice to yourself because
nobody's nice to anybody else if they
don't like themselves when people are
tearing down other people that just
exposes that they're hurt but if you're
lucky enough to feeling good give roses
to people because people are going to be
the fuel to get you there